une fois par semaine marie laure miro
seront au centre des restos du coeur de
rambouillet bonjour vous allez bien
un rendez vous pour lequel elle a ses
habitudes les scènes de près
comme chaque bénéficiaire des restos du
coeur elle était accompagnée d'un
bénévoles qui l'aident à composer son
panier en fonction du nombre de points
dont elle dispose pour elle et son fils
alors là oui on donne la viande donc on
nous propose un pote surgelé et du frais
une fois le caddie plein marie laure a
pour habitude de rester pour un café l
échange avec les bénévoles et les autres
bénéficiaires qui la connaissent bien
c'est toujours agréable
il ya deux ans marie laure subi de
lourdes opérations entraînant des arrêts
de travail prolongé auxiliaire de
puériculture elle ne peut plus porter
d'enfant elle est reconnue travailleuse
handicapée la microcrèche pour laquelle
elle travaille là les sensibles pour
inaptitude physique est très difficile
pour moi parce que du jour au lendemain
mais j'ai perdu mon
métier et puis mon envie d'exercer
c'était une passion pour moi sa pension
d'invalidité de deuxième catégorie 2 544
euros par mois et son allocation retour
à l'emploi d'environ 180 euros par mois
l'aide mais ne suffisent pas plus que
des paniers alimentaires les restos du
coeur lyon apporté du soutien dans cette
épreuve difficile
la joint l'espérance et puis nous
redonne à un punch
formidable parce que quand on est un peu
déprimé et tous des il arrive à nous
nous sortir la tête de l'eau bison
passionnel j'ai fait le tricot mais ça
fait aussi tricot thérapie enfin se
marie laure n'a jamais perdu le sourire
grâce à l'aide de son chien nacho et de
son fils vincent avec lequel elle
entretient une grande complicité tous
deux ont pu assister à un spectacle au
théâtre des champs elysées offert par
les restos du coeur on a eu des fous
rires avec mon fils et
mon ami qui du reste du coeur aussi qui
est mike qui était venu avec nous alors
voilà la fameuse photo avec un fou-rire
pour marie laure et son fils la
situation s'est améliorée elle a
retrouvé un emploi adapté à son handicap
elle est d'un enfant autiste dans son
programme scolaire 20 heures par semaine
avec ce revenu supplémentaire plus
besoin de se rendre aux restos du coeur
elle tient à laisser sa place à d'autres
personnes dans le besoin ils font
tellement chose pour nous que je vous
dire
on les remercie pas par l'argent mais on
les remercie
par des petits gestes etc
ici un scellé ouais je suis but parce
que si dijon mais formidable mais alors
qu art
battles 6